[inaudible]
hey guys,
so why would I ever write a
book again that is this big?
I had no plans to write Trevor mentors,
but this past year I turned 40 and a
lot happened in the last say 18 months.
A number of very close friends died.
I've had some very intense, uh,
family issues,
my extended family and all those things
led me in addition to growing out my
mystical beard to reassess my life and
to want to take a step back and do a
30,000 foot view and ask a
lot of really big questions.
And these tend to be the kind of
questions that I ask in many people ask at
different key forks in
the road, right? Or many,
many forks in the road where might be
college graduation might be the end of a
first job after the end of your first
major relationship or midlife crisis,
retirement and so on.
And I realized that I was still
struggling with a lot of things that were
longstanding, how to be kinder
to myself, how to say no,
how to separate the signal from the noise.
So of course as you get more successful
as anyone even has a small amount of
success, your problems don't
go away. You just trade up,
so you used to have the
say Pinto of problems,
then you get the Corolla of problems,
then you get the Mercedes of problems and
also your attackers and detractors get
more and more sophisticated, powerful
and so on. I was looking for help.
I was looking for help sorting out what
the next four years might look like and
for you that could be, you could be 20
it can be 80 the questions in the same,
many of the questions are the same
and I had a certain mentor group,
but I found myself trying to do it on my
own and I knew a lot of the same people.
Very, very smart. But I dreamed
of reaching out to certain folks.
Like what would Dan Gable,
legendary wrestling coach who
was a Demi God to me growing up,
what would he do in this scenario?
How would he think about physical training
after a certain age when maybe your
joints aren't what they used to be,
or if I wanted to 10 x 100 x my results,
what would one of the founders of
Facebook say or on a day to day basis what
tools they find most useful?
What do they travel with?
All of these types of questions led
me to then ask myself, all right,
I'm trying to do too much
heavy lifting on my own.
What would this look like if it were easy?
The answer I came up with in journaling
was reaching out to a dream list of
people and asking them all the same 11
questions are so some of them I'd refined
through the podcast. Tim Ferriss show
now has more than 200 million downloads.
Had a chance to really get to a surgical
precision with certain questions and
then a bunch of that I wanted to add.
What do you do when you feel
unfocused or overwhelmed?
Specifically what do you do or
what questions do you ask yourself?
How do you say no?
How have you built rules for yourself or
systems to say no to more things and so
on, and that's how we ended
up with tribe of mentors.
How did I choose people?
It's a really,
really eclectic group of people and I
actually want to read one quote at the
very,
very beginning that I thought it was
very important and relevant to my life in
this book, and this is from
Marcel Proust, p r o u s t quote.
The only true voyage would beat not to
travel through a hundred different lands
with the same pair of eyes,
but to see the same land through a
hundred different pairs of eyes. Right?
Do you have a different lens through which
to look at your challenges, problems,
opportunities,
relationships?
So I found 130 or so of them and I
want it to cover everything I wanted to
cover. Health, wealth,
happiness, fitness, longevity,
everything imaginable thinking systems.
So it ranges from say
writers and teachers,
Steven Pressfield, Susan Cain,
people that you may know,
like Terry crews for instance.
All of their lessons. Matt
Ridley Zone, Saint John,
I on Hirsi Ali.
It's a long list,
but then there are people you might
not recognize. And what I've found,
if you look at say the podcast of
the top six episodes of all time,
three of them,
50% are of people are involving people
you probably didn't hear of before the
podcast. So I'd say at
least, well first of all,
95% of the people in the book
have not been on the podcast.
And then at least half of them
you've probably never heard of.
But it includes the creators of a theory.
I'm all of these icons of cryptocurrency
actors and so on, like Ben Stiller.
Then you have crossfit champions,
Neil Gaiman,
temple Grandin athletes like Kelly
Slater who has the distinction of,
I think being the youngest person
ever to win the equivalent of a World
Championship and surfing and then the
oldest. All right, so how do you do that?
Right? What books have informed his
thinking and training and so on. Uh,
also,
one of the things that I did is as I
collected answers and interviewed people,
if a name came up repeatedly,
I would go after that name.
So say Steven Pinker,
you have say the authors of
Sapiens and Matt Ridley and so on.
All these names kept recurring.
So I reached out to them.
So you'll find as you read this
book, as they mentioned, mentors,
influences books and so on.
They're tied to other people in the book.
There's this entire web mesh of knowledge
and patterns and so few people who
have read this book,
my close friends like Matt Mullenweg
have said that it's easier,
it's easier to spot patterns in this
book than in any other book that I've put
together.
Uh,
so that allows you then end me to put
together a B spoke toolkit of your on for
any challenge, any opportunity that
you might have in front of you.
This has some type of tactic or routine
or tool that you can apply immediately
and it's intended to be used that way.
This is a reference book.
It's also a,
in case of emergency break glass book
that you can digest and tiny five to seven
page increments. It's not a to z. This
is a choose your own adventure book.
So that is how it came together.
I didn't plan to put it together.
It just needed to come together for me.
And hopefully you will find it
as useful as I have the guys,
is you're enjoying the tips
and tactics and how to,
on this channel or in the podcast, the
Tim Ferriss show, I made this for you.
Tribe of mentors,
short advice from the best in the world.
This is the book that I wanted to read.
So I went out and I put it together,
created a dream list of 130
of the best at what they do.
People who are icons, legends, and
ask them all the same questions.
These are people in some cases I wanted
to reach out to my whole life ranges
from many, many billionaires,
cofounders of every company imaginable,
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis, to powerlifting, everything else,
country stars, actors, directors,
and you can spot the patterns.
So some of my friends have said,
this is the easiest to read,
most useful book that
I've put together yet.
So checking out tribe of mentors.com
you can find sample chapters,
the whole list of mentors,
everything, tribal mentors.com.